[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
three
[Music]
what's poppin y'all welcome back to
another episode of bleacher reports
pre-game picks the only show in the
world where
you the people at home can win free cash
prizes by simply predicting random [ __ ]
that occurs in the nba pregame
as always i'm your host pierre akap with
the plug and i got my boy famous lost
with me lost what's poppin
what's poppin what's good pee wee bat
baby we back what we betting on today
what are we back
today brother hey we we we back and we
got a big show ahead of us
so hey let's get this [ __ ] started
mm-hmm
let's get started
we always keep it clean wow
my name is i told y'all welcome to
pregame picks let's
get it welcome back
to pregame picks i'm joined by my boy
famous los los was popping talk to me
how you doing
how you feeling we got a big game ahead
of us man lakers nets what's going on
i'm feeling good man it's about to get
real scary we playing we got the nets in
the lakers come on man
come on man hey i'm ready to get i'm
ready to give away a lot of money
you ready to give away some money let's
give it away brother
all right so first things first before
we get into everything tonight we'll be
doing things a little bit different in
the past we've had people going into the
app early in the day and make their
pregame picks but tonight
we're gonna be picking winners live from
the comments that's right
live from the comments so don't worry if
you ain't doing nothing early in the day
about anything from the past tonight
we're gonna be making pics as a family
so make sure you're in the comments
letting me and those know what you
thinking and what your opinions are when
a
when the pics pop up so speaking of the
picks lost let's take a look at what we
have tonight
and let's get it so first thing first we
got
will we see lebron and kyrie dapp up
we also have the over and under on
20 and a half made shots from lebron
those are made shots emphasis on made
shots i think last episode with some
confusion and then last but not least we
have or the final shot
of the lakers warm-up be a make or a
miss lost what's standing out to you in
this prompt today
[Music]
we'll we see lebron and kyrie deppa the
first one
so let's get into that wha what's what's
your thoughts about that is that a
no-brainer
are you not that's a no-brainer why why
wouldn't they dab
up why wouldn't they that book kyrie
y'all seen kyrie kyrie really peaceful
right now he might give him a hug
hey you know that that's a fact i
wouldn't be surprised if we see a hug
but you know sometimes sometimes
competitors they like to come out and
act like hey man it's not but you're
right
i think i'm gonna go with the uh go with
that everybody
you gotta show love you gotta show love
ain't no we but yeah you right we kind
of passed that
we kind of passed the whole lebron kyrie
thing that's been a minute
yeah we're not these not women we talk
about these growing men we talk about
but they dapping those
they get they dapp it up then they get
into it what you mean it's a business
it's about
i feel you i feel i want to remind the
people at home real quick lows
that right now is a time for them to be
in the comments letting us know what
they think again we gonna be making
these decisions as a family
so y'all drop the comments let us know
if y'all think lebron and kyrie will be
dapping up
in the pre-game and we will have
production take a look at those comments
and we'll we'll make our decision as a
family so we already seen some years
we're seeing some years
i think the people rolling with us yeah
yeah they they
saying yeah um while we wait for them no
yes sir that's what i want to get into i
want to get into kyrie
so you are known as the guy that loves
breaking down moves
what can we expect from kyrie tonight
here on the main stage in la this is a
tv game
what should we be expecting from kyrie
5 36 36 about 36 chicken nuggets
30 36 30 why you say dale why do you say
damn
that's light that's like 30 seconds 36 a
lot of points
that's a lot of points though who's
checking who's checking oh
man i don't i don't i don't have i don't
have that answer but i ain't know he was
going into his bag that deep
he just missed the last game listen to
melissa hey it's k.d playing that's
awesome is kitty playing
no katie is not playing it's only hard
and kyrie tonight okay
kyrie 36 hearted 29
13 and 11. i said it what are we getting
what are we getting from the king though
what are we getting from the king
from brian we're getting 28
11. okay and okay nine twenty eight
eleven and nine okay
now wait wait look how read 36 points
are we going to see someone with john
marin gave us last night i saw you
reacting to that john moran had some
boys on skates
oh my god he tried to kill him he tried
to kill her last night
behind the back beat snatch back the
stash back do it because he already
leaned he already leaned so he snatched
back so if you don't know about
basketball they're already leaning just
snatch back he's going
to keep stumbling just talk to yourself
moves.com
but yeah you learn something you learn
something you learn something new every
day shout out to those teaching the kids
at home man
i like yeah but kyrie is gonna be yeah
kyrie definitely gonna be banking
tonight it's gonna get ugly watch
listen to me watch
so while we wait i want to re-emphasize
to y'all
we are picking our picks as a family so
i want y'all in the comments to let us
know are you predicting lebron and kyrie
to dab
yes or no whichever one is prominent in
the comments whatever one is the
majority we're gonna roll with as a
family tonight we are winning as a
family we're losing as a family so if we
pick a year and they do
we're gonna pick five of y'all from the
comments who said yeah
and y'all are taking home 200 tonight
and that will be the thing that's how
we're rocking tonight we're winning as a
family we're losing as a family so y'all
make sure y'all active in those comments
and don't leave because you don't want
to miss the chance to take home
200 speaking of kyrie and lebron
lost we got the all-stars uh announced
what did you think about the all-star
starters would you happy please did
anybody get snubbed talk to me
i mean i like it but you see the
internet going off with dame but of
course dame you know dan should be
starting
they should be starting but they want
luca to be out but
damn luca average 29 right now
so he could be started i know you know
people talk about luca like he like he
asked
but but they but okay but they should be
starting because they ain't really doing
this without
cj he's doing this thing yeah luca lucas
buddy kp yes christopher zayn
yeah that luca got him right now
if you had to pick one you taking damn
then
uh i ain't picking come on now
no no no no don't do that don't do that
i'm not doing it do not do that
i'm gonna give you ten seconds i'm gonna
give you ten seconds to think about that
i wanna remind the people that next we
have the over or under on lebron
made shots again lebron made shots 20
and a half is he going to go over is he
going to be under
only made shots i think last episode we
had to confuse on the zion shots people
thought we meant shots in total but we
are counting the maid
baskets while we wait for lebron and
kyrie to dab
up i'm waiting for my man lois to let me
know is damn
luca his pick for all-star talk to him
damn
damn that's my boy what you mean i ain't
never met luca dave my boy
and he gonna put 30 on your head stupid
that's why
cause he's so when you when you make
your picks it's about
who you met who you didn't meet yeah
this one because he's my boy
this is because he's my mans that's why
what about you
what about your mans what about your man
steph would you take dame over steph
as far as this all-star game not it not
in general just his all-star game
would i take dave over steph i just told
you dave was my man then
so you oh [ __ ] last time i talked stuff
with your man nah
don't do that boy like that no don't
leave that boy like that
let me finish i said you know i just
told you dang my man so whatever i'm
about to say
he should take it to heart
you remix it up you remix it i feel i
respect it i respect it hey
i want to know if we can get some i want
to see some other angles
in the arena right now i want to know
what's going on i i maybe want to throw
in some side action do we got anybody
setting out some chairs do we got
anybody eating anything
do we have anybody mopping the floor
look at my boy you know him you know him
no sir
no sir but i love him what you think
he's about to do
what do you think he's about to do right
now boy he just poured a water bottle
out of his back pocket
hey i wish i wish we that's how bronzo
look at three years
you petty it's like lebron is going to
still be in
the envelope yeah that's how bryan go
look at in the finals in three years
hey he was he was smooth okay
here we go we we let what we got going
on right here i i can't tell we got an
empty tunnel
okay these are the blocks okay supposed
to be running out of hey
pete that's why i supposed to be running
out here for real though
bro i really shouldn't be talking to
y'all i really shouldn't be able to be
playing
with y'all you know what we need to do
bro
after this season we need to link up in
the summer
and we need to get our you know what i'm
saying get get our workouts in so we can
get a 10 day
what team you trying to get on man i'm a
nick fan i'm trying to get on the knicks
bro
you're trying to get on the [ __ ] so yo
yo you don't give a damn by winning
hey it's 20 and a half for here we go we
got bricker coming out of the tunnel
did you see did you see harding did you
see harder
yeah so hard he wasn't he wasn't last
though
you told me the best player is supposed
to be last boy they got so many damn
guys it was deandre jordan
you even know who gonna be last night
for the next
for the next prop before we get to kyrie
and lebron potentially dapping up or not
um it's 20 and a half a good over under
for lebron i know last episode you
didn't know what over under was so if
you need
me to re-explain it let me know and i
decided to do that for you but
okay so the the over under water lake
has come out of the tunnel
um is do you think lebron is going to
make 21 shots
or lower do i think lebron 21
oh he's gonna make 21. yes
in in warm-ups though made shots okay so
we got the lebron
counter up we're about to get started
let's see what his first oh he rebounded
okay cause last last time we had the
confusion they switched lines on them
and did we see that yeah that's what
wait i don't know oh they dapping up yet
they dapping up when the when the goons
when the ghoul's about to get going they
go down
what did it wait watching so low it dug
in it back okay i just
i just got word from production wow
that is a why that is why because we
take it
as a family we are picking over so
everybody in the comments the majority
pick was over they think he's gonna make
more than 20 and a half shots and that's
off to a bad start so
he just missed the layup exactly we off
to a bad start i'm trying to get some
people some money at home man so lebron
don't let us down
don't let us down bro what
is that was that was that he missed
another one he missed the game
[Applause]
lebron we got 15 minutes left i hope
lebron
is is getting this stuff together for
y'all
he knows
come on bro come on brian i don't like
all the smiles
activity look at brian come on okay
that's the one there we go
we got we got off the first that's all
we had to see was one go through the
basket
that's all we have to do get your jelly
fam on you know uh you got any that in
your game
is you just a shoot or can you can you
yeah can you jelly can you get something
make it look sexy i'm 31 bro i don't
jelly
i lay it up i get lays lays oh
how old is lebron
that's two that was no jelly good job
bro why make sure that but it was some
sexiness
it was blind
that was another miss if he don't make
more than 21
how many i say brian we're gonna have
29.
27 man no you're not you said yeah you
said 28 or 29
hey can i get a word for production as a
family are we picking kyrie and lebron
dapping yes or no i never got word on
that i want to i want to talk
okay so by the way people at home
we are picking that lebron and kyrie
will dap i know y'all dominated that
in the comments section so hopefully
they do that so we can get y'all some
more money and hopefully lebron come on
lebron you gotta get your [ __ ] together
man
this is what i was talking about in the
last episode nba players in the warm-ups
they try to look sexy man they try to
look sexy
i'm bad as hell right now and i'm mad
too because i don't i'm not even sure we
gonna get lebron and kyrie to dab up it
looked like we just got jared dudley and
joe
stepping up no dude look look they gonna
dab up and brian go make 21. but what oh
my god
oh my god step back stupid watch it
watch them that look good
that uh kyrie ain't on the court yet so
we still got a chance to get that that
paper for them
on the carry on after the starting
lineup when they about to go out and
then google was about to get the going
going at it that's when they go um boom
that's when they go down
they're not about that point right now
but we need we need we need them to dab
in the pre-game low this is hey bro hey
bro hey bro
brian just made it all right now i'm
watching y'all
hey make it come on bro put it okay put
it
put a pep in your step my boy say he
built by black history
shout out to the pajamas
you see brian shoulder that ball like
that way
look at him now talk to me about lebron
free throw routine they say that's
lebron achilles heel is the free throws
what he needs to do to boost himself up
to the upper echelon of free throw
percentages we need let's see lebron 85
percent
up what he need to do let's say break
down his free throw free throw routine
what's wrong with him and why why can't
he be upper echelon 80.
come on this this all subject but i was
91 percent of high school fun
from the line but anyway and he need to
he need to take that damn blow out pause
the little
the love okay he need to take it out you
got to go
go straight in rhythm straight up where
the boom boom straight
to your shot
loki he real he will do that [ __ ] he
will do that
he will say he be he be doing a little
jersey thing
too yeah that's what you i know i know i
yeah i know i look crazy right now y'all
but that's what the blog i don't know
what you're doing bud
come on boy you're making me come on
come on man
come on man let's not do that let's not
do that you already like you let's not
do that
you like scared
before i get before i get started on you
we halfway home lebron got 11. we got 11
minutes left
that means we that much closer for some
people at home to take home 200
that's right for all of y'all that may
have missed it or just got here for
whatever reason
tonight we are making our picks as a
family so early in the show
the comments were dominated with lebron
taking the over
on 20 and a half shots made in pre-games
so we already 11.
we got the uh with lebron and kyrie
dabbing pregames we got the year
so we are hoping and anticipating that
they will dap up so we can send
five people home with 200 for each
question and then we're going to end the
night with will the lakers
end on a make or a miss um
with the last shot of pre-games we just
had lost breaking down lebron
free throw routine and how he can get
that percentage up lo said he got to
take out the
whatever that is i don't even know what
to call it you call that the blowout
yeah blow it out pause pause pause man
what the [ __ ] what's going on
we we park we pausing but it's the
blowout
what's going on hey who got your
favorite free throw routine
ever uh they got kyrie by the way
steph steph it's just one bounty shooter
i think i think it's just one bout to
shoot it
hey do you remember when richard
hamilton used to dribble to the side
yeah i love it i love it you remember
who
who used to shoot who used to shoot
halfway from the um from the from the
back oh nick van impe
uh dwight howard doing that right now
dwight how are we doing now
in the middle yeah he can take a step
back a far as free throw i don't know
i i maybe because he think he's strong
as hell
if you can't shoot me but would you do
that
but listen before we go in on the white
we 16
shots made for lebron that mean we are
five away from potentially sending
people home
with 200 dollars a piece that's five
winners we're gonna be selecting
oh hey lebron about to do it don't do it
bro don't do it
don't do it okay if you vote with us if
you voted with us you about to win so
you know you bout to win
if you voted where's devil vote against
us we like brady
hey bronze brian scared me i thought he
was about to go sit down
before oh my god look look look look
look y'all see
him y'all see kyrie oh my god look at
brian brown you ain't going to get in
his bag
hey keep it on kyrie for one second oh
my god oh my god hey
he gonna kill somebody tonight he might
kill somebody right what's your call
what you call it
you better throw that you better throw
that shot right right missing we still
three away we got plenty of time hey i
think
i think i think we can start clapping we
can start clapping
we can start look at the two oh my god
big bank this house
come on come on brian let's let's get
this money
let's get this money let's get this hell
no bro i'm running around i'm
come on yeah that's my damn goat don't
don't disrespect him don't do that first
of all first of all
don't do it one more
did you see that well where the hell you
get that shirt from take it back
that's my job
i know he'll be there oh my god brian
the best player i've ever seen in my
entire life living i swear to god why's
the best player i've ever seen today
yeah
shut up brian that's that's why brianna
go so
that means five people are going to be
going home with 200
because they roll with us looks that
like you said that's what you do yes
don't bet again
don't bet against us roll with the
winners
that's one more time let's look at the
let's look at his reaction look at it
look at it yeah
look at him go look hannah we call that
ghost [ __ ]
we call
so the last one that we got is the make
or miss lakers final shot
of uh pregame man
hey there we go lois here we go these
are winners right here taking home 200
cause they roll with us kyle daniel 22 i
think i've seen that name before that
boy getting a lot of money from br
he getting a lot of money and then we
got ring underscore season he sound like
a laker fan
ring caesar lois if you were taking home
200
what would you be doing with that money
or what advice do you got for these
winners
that are taking home that 200 talk to
them
what i would do with 200 right now i
would give it back to the community
well they obviously they they not going
to get that money to the damn community
you got to put yourselves in their shoes
what would i do with two i i buy some
feel good pause
my myself have a have me a good night
have me a good night
you know uh uh then by some unnecessary
wait how much is 200
that ain't a lot of money though is it
is that a lot
it can you do a lot depending on who
depending on who it is those nights
eating good so eating good i'm eating
good i'm eating good
eating i'm eating eating good only only
in l.a
only in l.a one meal 200 to be honest
with you
only in l.a one bill 200.
offering a hood that 200 is stretched
out if we talk about yeah
what i'm thinking 200 i'm on there all
week and a half seriously
okay okay that's light
that's light that's light yeah you know
he had that what you what you mean what
the hell
is that he had
that might be his only dunk what duck
contest
the duke duke dunk contest oh okay
yeah yeah yeah no no about you wouldn't
know that about duke bro i'm from durham
don't don't even don't even don't don't
stop
stop stop playing with me bro stop doing
i'm just saying stop just saying
duke i'm just saying i only let people
talk about it come on now
hey shout out to sean dockery shout out
to sean docker
we talking about dude hey that's hey
that's
that he won a deal he won a deal though
he wanted
come on now come on now so you know i
know
you know i know hey if you say that name
you know you know
but i i want i want to tell you some
news that
that could that could have us a little
shaky loss yeah
lebron just walked off the court they
ain't dapped yet
it don't matter no dude so do they have
to death in these four minutes
yes this is the pre-game this is
pre-game picks
you know they have to death in pre-game
yes but they're gonna adapt when
when when when it's walking out and the
game about this far
oh my god oh my god hey
if we don't if we don't see it it don't
count so everybody at home
i'm letting y'all i'm letting y'all know
if we don't see it then it don't count
that that's what i'm getting word from
for production if we don't see them
shake hands in this pregame right here
technically we lose and i believe we
picked yeah
so um i'm gonna put that blame on lowe's
lois that's on you
you told them terrible james looked
terrible
kyrie just dunked that with two hands
like that on james did you just see that
i didn't please rewind this i get a
report why did it replay it right now
look how he just dumped this you talking
about some dewey got that
you talking about some dude he got that
well that's my third cousin twice for
move
hey you know what listen because lebron
walked off the court
and we might not get them to death up
check it out lois
as a family we picking that the final
shot the lakers warm up is gonna be in
make
and we feeling generous so instead of
five winners we gonna pick
ten we doubling up the lakers better
make that shot
so ten our peoples in the comments can
go home with two hundred dollars
how you feeling you rocking with me is
you rocking or you rolling let's go
let's go i'm rocking in i'm rolling with
you brother what you mean
let's go so let's go come on like us
yeah this all right uh
my shirt my shirt my shirt is lit as
hell but hey
y'all getting those comments right now
make or miss make or miss
load them comments up so 10 of y'all can
get a chance to take home
200 dollars i don't know where lebron
went that's the best player i ain't
never delicious right there no
no i
uh the best sound lakers right there
backing up to the top of the key
hold on boy boy hell no
right there
sorry i wanted to talk about po i'm
talking about
speaking of duke shout out quinn cook
that's another dukey
[Music]
happy birthday pope happy birthday pope
happy birthday listen
scratch that hey between me and you can
i get a clock up for 30 seconds real
quick while we wait on
to make a miss 30 second clock i'll put
lows on the spot
we gonna make a bet for 15 jumping jacks
right here live on the camera i want you
to name as many duke players as you can
in 30 seconds if you name more than
if you name 20 or more
i i i i'm a countdown
is you ready yes
20 or more five four three
two start one sean dougherty
four five chris duhon
harry irvin
he left uh daniel ewan 13
14. jason williams 16.
18. 19. 20. ewing
twenty-one you and i don't know none of
them new boys i don't know no new ones
jason potato marvin bagley
i've
we down to the left i ain't i ain't even
gonna hold you
that might have been too hard i thought
you knew something man come on man cam
ready
rj barrett austin rivers seth curry
quinn cook yeah yeah here we go
what do you think about all that here we
go
it's going to be amazing 10 winners wait
wait dude is it over come on no watch
watch
they still shooting they still came out
it don't count it don't count yeah hold
on don't couch it one more one more shot
hold up
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait what the hell is going on come on
wait wait wait wait he won't did the
lights go off
there we go there we go there we go
[Applause]
happy birthday boy shout out kcp baby
hold on let's see if pope made that
cause it looked like it was all air
he made that he made that did he made
that let me see
he said he said let me get that back he
said let me get that back oh my god
they didn't touching this pokemon
10 people going home with 200 dollars
courtesy of us because they they was
rocking with us shout out to y'all for
flooding them comments
letting us know what y'all got again
tonight's
episode we made pics as a family we lost
as a family we won as a family
and because of that ten people are going
home with two hundred dollars
um loss
we do this [ __ ] if i mean people
i'm satisfied i'm happy bro i feel good
so so take that 10 and add the five
because lebron made his 21 shots
15 people going home with 200 dollars
fifteen people yeah
we got it oh yeah this is a good day
yeah 15.
i know you can't count you thought it
was 14 at first you thought i ain't
heard
you thought you thought i i ain't hear
you you you saying 14.
you was over that count you
education what they call it when you
graduate top of your class
what honors no
magna [ __ ] laude kiss my man now pina
colada
not now pina colada
next thursday we're gonna be here
playing again pelicans versus bucks
shout out to our boy zl2 brandon ingram
that's another dookie boy
that's another dookie that's a hey
that's a nokia lana boy
hey people don't know you played against
him in high school him and reggie
bullock
yeah hey no you don't know that hey i
looked today i looked today
brandon eagle wasn't on team reggie was
on the team
okay okay brandon brandon was too young
brandon was too young
hey it's on my story right now he's too
young
yeah i'm 31 bro grown as hell hey
check y'all dms we're giving away we
picking 10 winners for the last one the
make or miss we ended on the make we win
as a family we send a 10 of y'all home
with 200 from that so check y'all dms
make sure you check in mdm's
hey los my brother we had another good
night i love it hey who you got winning
tonight who y'all got winning tonight
the next i got the lakers that's my
three you got the next
yeah sir 10 push-ups yes sir we out
yes sir we out
[Music]
you